basically throwing to chrissy serving as
his catcher to try and keep his arm
loose
and he gets a good swing and a miss
there on a down and in breaking ball
chase de young with back-to-back
strikeouts getting olson to end the
first and grossman to start the second
swing and a miss chase de young getting
three straight strikeouts matt olson
robbie grossman and now chris davis two
away in the second looks like that
slider's working pretty good on that
arms or on that glove side
and then contributing as he just did
leading off this ending with a base hit
now jonah heim
here's the ball sent high in the air
into shallow left field correa is
calling off brantley carlos makes a
tough catch
brantley's looking at him like that
could have been my ball a little easier
but carlos made the call and the catch
for out number one
top of the order tommy la stella
right center field that's gonna be a
base hit machine digging around second
he's gonna hustle to third
runners at the corners here in the
bottom of the third with one out
[Applause]
kemp drives on the right field tucker
back
tucker waiting he's got it machine tags
he's going to come in and he will score
so tony kemp
does his job his sacrifice fly in these
jump ahead one nothing here in the third
three two two outs runner goes and the
balls line center field base hit with
stella will hustle around to third
and lorianna would have a [ __ ] so good
at bet for ramon laureato so here's
olson
deep to right
and
that baby is go
three-run shot for matt olson
they still be in the air
100th career home run for matt olsen it
has not taken him long to get to that
number
that was a missile shot
oh
my
you hang it they bang it
a walk to load the bases and bring the
tying run to the plate here in the
fourth inning
that hit correa with the bases loaded
that's gonna
force in a run and give the astros their
first run of the game carlos correa hit
by a pitch it's now a four to one
contest the straw jogs in from third so
this is a big pitch and as i say that
you can probably call me captain obvious
if you'd like it is three tooth faces
loaded
down and in ball four the astros have
had two runs score in the inning without
the benefit of putting the ball in play
a hit batter and now a walk and it's a
4-2 game as brantley crosses the plate
3-0 the count base is loaded the astros
already with two runs in the inning one
on a hit batter with a base of loaded
one on a walk and that is low ball four
a four pitch walk to dustin garneau who
drives in a run it's now a four to three
game
the astros have scored their last three
runs without putting the ball in play
george up the middle this has a chance
to get through play by tony capp not in
time we're tied up at four
george springer an infield hit
and the astros with a four run fourth
inning to answer the a's four run third
so with tommy listella coming up and the
go ahead run at third gusty baker says i
want brooks raley
popped up
shallow left toro goes out and he makes
the catch just
in fair territory a basket catch over
his shoulder abraham toro saves a run
for the astros
we head to the fifth tied at four
greatly to third with one out
right to kemp nice hop flips to first so
that's a huge out
bradley is the runner at third so this
is a big
big out to get for lou trevino let lou
bury this if he needs to
doesn't need to he strikes out carlos
curry on three pitches brantley the
go-ahead run is stranded he's got
something cooking here with two outs the
bases are loaded for tommy la stella
0-2 pitch sending the air to left field
michael brantley back he'll have a play
the base is left loaded a couple of
walks in a base hit but annoli paredes
gets through the sixth and the astro
glad the base is loaded for yuli guriel
yuli sends one to center field deep
enough to score a run springer will tag
from third straw going back to tag from
second the throw comes into second
astros take their first lead of the
series it's 5-4 on the sac fly by euler
guriel there was ever a big spot for
ryan presley to close the door this
would be it
popped up
on the infield abraham toro is there the
astros win game two of the double header
ryan pressley has saved all three of the
astros wins against the a's this year
this was a big big win for the houston
astros